on reste à Tours car aujourd'hui nous
fêtons les 10 ans de la ligne A du tram
un nouveau service qui a transformé la
ville tant au niveau de l'aménagement
urbain qu'en termes de mobilité elle
dessert 77000 habitants et notamment 4
quartiers relevant de la politique de la
ville pour cet anniversaire Clémence
d'OSC nous fait remonter le temps et
revient sur ce projet monumental qui a
nécessité deux ans de travaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était le 31 août 2013 à 13h tapante le
tramway arrivé place Jean Jaurès une
célébration de la mise en service de la
ligne A en grande pompe entre animations
et gratin politique
[Musique]
ont profité d'un week-end de gratuité
pour tester ce transport l'aboutissement
pour certains d'un projet de vie ça a
été magique
j'avais des étoiles dans les yeux et
pour moi ça a été un pour un projet que
je portais depuis de très nombreuses
années avec tenacité et c'était la
réalisation de l'aboutissement de la
réalisation de cette première ligne et
quand j'ai vu la population la propriété
dans les jours qui ont suivi c'était
remarquable deux années de travaux ont
été nécessaires pour aménager les 14,8
km de voies dont une partie est
électrifiée au sol intégration dans le
paysage piétonnisation de la rue
Nationale et changement de circulation
le tramway a profondément redessiné
l'espace et la façon de vivre la ville
la tranchée 7% de pente c'est pas là où
c'est le plus Portu c'est plutôt vers
gammart et un tramway peut monter avec
le type de matériel qu'on a 10% de
dénivelé donc il y avait pas un sujet
donc fallait l'expliquer on va il y a eu
des calculs il a fallu qu'on s'explique
mais le tram est là le pont est là et la
tranchée là donc l'histoire nous a donné
raison
désormais emprunté par 65 000 voyageurs
chaque jour le succès de la première
ligne semble faire l'unanimité sociale
environnementale mobilité le tram est un
objet politique investi par les
municipalités et élu successifs il faut
rappeler que avant tout ce projet de
mobilité c'est aussi pour sauver
l'environnement pour améliorer réduire
la pollution dans l'atmosphère et il
faut se rappeler que le tram peut
emmener 300 personnes 300 personnes
c'est 150 véhicules et on estime à peu
près à 25000 trajets voiture qui sont
économisées finalement grâce au tram de
nombreuses animations fêteront le tram
jusqu'au mois de septembre prochaine
étape la ligne 2 prévue pour 2028